When it comes to gender disparity, the world
of commercial airline piloting is one of the
most skewed with a whopping 97% of all commercial
pilots being male (4000 female commercial
pilots vs. 130,000 male worldwide according
to The International Society of Women Airline
Pilots).
Those numbers shift slightly when you factor
in women who are qualified to fly private
planes but not commercial.
But there is still a huge difference in the
number of males compared to females even in
this case.
According to the US Civil Airmen Statistics,
in 2011 there were about 617,000 qualified
pilots in the United States, 41,000 of which
were women, which means just over 93% of all
pilots in 2011 were men.
So what gives here?
Do women just not like flying?
Are the airline industry and the training
schools just sexist?
On the latter issue, at one point like in
so many industries, yes.
As discussed in this article on Helen Richey,
who became the world’s first female pilot
“to fly a commercial airliner on a regularly
scheduled mail route” on December 31, 1934,
she quit after only 10 months due to how poorly
she was treated by male staff.
Among other things, Richey was barred from
becoming a member of the Pilot’s Union and
was forbidden from flying in anything other
than fair weather.
It should be noted here that these restrictions
were being placed on a woman who once crawled
onto the wing of a plane she was flying to
repair a tear.
She also spent years flying stunt planes.
Another thing that historically was holding
early female pilots back was the fact that
to become a commercial pilot, one needed to
be subjected to various strength and height
requirements.
Since women are generally shorter than men
and there is often a disparity in physical
strength, many women were barred from even
applying to become a pilot.
However, in recent years this has gotten much
better, to quote The International Society
of Women Airline Pilots: “These requirements
have mainly fallen by the wayside.
The only requirement is that a prospective
pilot can fly the simulator provided during
the interview process, without undue problems
due to height or strength.”
As for the issue of sexism in more modern
times, according to pilot and editor of Aviation
for Women magazine, Amy Laboda, “I can tell
you that [female airline pilots] have made
tremendous progress, and the reason … is
because most of the dinosaurs are gone…
The men who didn’t want women in the cockpit
have mostly retired.”
Today, it’s generally not so much that those
within the industry have any issues with female
pilots, but, interestingly enough, the people
who respond most poorly are the passengers.
Within the industry, there’s actually been
a huge drive by some airlines in recent years,
for example by British Airways, to increase
the number of females applying for given positions,
and thus hopefully start to even out the numbers.
So with some companies, while you’re still
going to need to bring the skills and the
experience to the table, you actually might
have a leg up on the competition at the moment
if you’re a woman trying to become a commercial
pilot.
If you’ve got the same skill and experience
as a male applying, one would think the companies
looking for more female pilots will pick you
over your equivalent XY competition.
So why haven’t the numbers evened out since
the sexist “dinosaurs” have all retired?
Well one theory is that the sheer amount of
time one needs to dedicate to being a pilot,
and brutal travel schedule, turns a lot of
women off because they’d rather focus on
their domestic life and stay closer to home.
This is a nice theory and perhaps is a factor,
but there are only colloquial sources to back
it up.
Further, the same can be said about a lot
of industries that don’t see anywhere near
a 4,000 vs. 130,000 type split in number of
women vs. men working in the respective fields.
Another theory is that, for whatever reason,
young girls never see being a pilot as a career
option whether because the field doesn’t
fit young girls’ interests or perhaps simply
because you rarely see female commercial pilots
in real life or on TV or movies; so there
is a lack of visible role models.
A study conducted by British Airways in their
efforts to learn why more women don’t become
commercial pilots discovered that among young
boys, “pilot” was the second most popular
career choice.
With girls, it wasn’t even mentioned.
So whatever the underlying reason, most young
girls just don’t find becoming a commercial
pilot appealing.
This also, perhaps, explains why the numbers
are so skewed even in the private pilot license
arena, still with a 93%/7% male vs. female
split.
All that said, it’s generally thought that
the biggest factor stopping women from becoming
commercial pilots is the fact that a lot of
pilots come from a military background, an
option that wasn’t even open to women in
many countries (and some still not) until
relatively recently.
In the U.S., for instance, until 1993 women
weren’t allowed to fly combat aircraft.
So if a woman wanted to become a commercial
pilot before such restrictions were lifted,
they’d have to foot the $100,000-ish bill
to acquire all the necessary training and
experience.
And keep in mind, commercial pilots just starting
out don’t get paid much.
According to FAPA (Future and Active Pilot
Advisers), first officers can start out as
low as $20,000 per year.
Needless to say, investing those same dollars
and hours into other careers can often be
much more lucrative, particularly up front.
As commercial pilot Jill Schilmoeller said,
“You have to love flying, because you start
off getting paid horribly and you are gone
a lot…”
To get around the training cost, one essentially
has to join the military, where once again
we find a huge disparity in the desire to
do so in men vs. women.
So not only do we have an issue of young girls
not dreaming of becoming pilots, but we also
have significantly less women joining the
military and becoming pilots there, and maybe
making “commercial pilot” a future option
for themselves, even if they didn’t think
of it as an option as a child.
While most men also don’t see the military
as an option they want to pursue, the small
number that do and then become pilots there
still eclipse the number of women doing it.
Combined with the cost of getting the training
all yourself without the military footing
the bill, this results in a relatively huge
pool of men applying for commercial pilot
positions compared to women.
So when it all shakes out, even without any
sexism in the industry itself, the result
is that, at least for now, it will be a rare
flight you take where one of the people flying
the plane is a woman.